Okay.
So we're at the conclusion,
we're at the conclusion of,
um,
of studying our theoretical study of bonds and reactivity.
Uh,
then we'll go on to something completely different and we're ending by talking
about reactivity in terms of for functional groups.
And you're doing your own functional groups,
I remember for tomorrow.
Okay.
Uh,
so we already talked about carbon eel last time and now we're going to go onto a
mid carboxylic acid and kill lithium as other functional groups and then we'll
do something just completely different for the next,
uh,
quarter of the semester.
Okay?
Uh,
so resonance is Homo Lubo mixing that happens within a molecule.
The molecule of course knows all about it.
It only becomes resonance because we draw a picture that's too simple and we
need to modify the picture,
right?
And that modification is called resonance.
And a good example of that is the amid functional group.
Now,
when I include an amid on the first exam where people are supposed to identify
functional groups,
circle them and name them,
it's inevitable that some people will circle to see double Bondo and say,
that's a carbonyl group.
And some people will circle it,
circle the nitrogen and say that's an amine.
But an amid is not an amine and it's not a key tone or a carbonyl group.
It's its own thing.
And the,
the reason is that those interact with one another in a way that makes them no
longer like an amine and no longer like a carbon eel group.
That's resonance.
So we'll look at it here in terms of d two different pictures of the molecule.
One is as a carbonyl amine and the other is as an amid,
which if you're in the Lewis structures,
you draw with a double headed Arrow and show two uh,
two resonance structures and you have in the carbon eel and a,
you identify a homo that makes the thing of base and a Lumo that should make it
an acid.
But resonance is an e is can be thought of as an reaction already within the
molecule between the Homo in the Lumo and it's a make and break situation just
like we saw with between molecules last time where the unshared pair makes a new
bond.
In this case,
the second of a double bond and something leaves from the carbon that's being
attacked.
The thing that leaves is the second bond of a double bond.
So it's another one of these make and break situations.
But in this case it's a correction to our naive localized picture of that we
drew at the beginning.
Okay,
so let's see about this.
First we have the naive prediction,
what that should say about the characteristics of the molecule and then what the
experimental observation is,
which requires that we use something more complicated.
The resonance structures or thinking in terms of molecular orbitals.
Okay.
So,
uh,
the amines and carbon heels are perfectly stable molecules in terms of being low
energy.
They don't just do something,
but what's associated with the idea of resonance structures is the thing is more
stable than you would have predicted if you didn't consider the resonance
structure.
So you say that's more stable and you can see why it would be more stable
because the unshared pair is mixing with a vacant orbital and becoming lower in
energy.
In fact,
the observation is that it's more stable by about 16 kilocalories per mole,
which about a fourth as much as a carbon nitrogen bond is worth.
So it's a significant amount of energy.
Now,
if you have a CN single bond that's longer than a double bond and longer than a
partial CN double bond that you'd have for the average of the resonance
structures on the right.
And in fact,
that bond is shorter than normal single nitrogen carbon bonds by about 0.1 for
OnX drums.
Okay.
On the left,
you have a short double bond for CW Bondo,
but on the right,
it's a partial single bond.
So it should be longer,
not held as tightly,
and in fact,
it is longer than others.
C O double bonds by about 0.03 Ostrom's.
Okay.
Uh,
we've seen before when we were talking about x,
h three y nitrogen tends to be pyramidal,
so as to give s character to the unshared pair of electrons.
But on the right,
if it's going to be part of a double bond,
it has to be plainer and we can see why that is.
So here's the Pi Star Lumo of the CW Bondo.
And here in front is the unshared pair on nitrogen in a PR battle,
which overlaps and d localizes mixes with the vacant Lumo,
right?
That means that you have a partial double bond for the CN and a partial single
bond for the CEO.
How is it that putting an electron's makes it a single bond rather than a double
bond?
Why would putting in electrons weaken a bond?
Alex can't hear because it's an anti-bonding orbital,
the Pi Star of CEO.
Okay.
Now,
so it's plainer indeed,
and I'll show you pictures that prove it,
uh,
because it gives the overlap.
If there were an s p hybrid on the nitrogen,
the s part of it wouldn't overlap with the p Pi.
So a pure p orbital gives the best overlap.
So that's why it's plainer from an molecular orbital point of view.
Uh,
now if you have a single bond,
it's easy for things to rotate around it because it's cylindrically symmetric.
But we know that a Pi bond is not cylindrically symmetric.
It is that oval shape.
So there's a barrier to rotation about the central bond of a carbon carbon
double bond.
Yeah,
because when you rotate the nitrogen in front like this,
by 90 degrees,
you've wrecked the overlap that allowed those electrons to be stabilized.
Right.
In fact,
once you've done this,
there's no reason for the nitrogen to be sp squared hybridized anymore because
the,
the unshared pair is not trying to overlap with the carbon p orbital behind it.
Right.
So it might as well hybrid eyes and become sp squared the way it normally does
and this structure,
the halfway rotated structure turns out to be 16 kilocalories more stable than
the one our,
pardon me,
less stable than the one where you do have the overlap.
So twisting it has a barrier of 16 kilocalories from all.
Have you ever seen that number before,
Zach?
That's what we saw at the beginning.
It's more stable when those electrons can be stabilized as compared to enemy in
and a carbon eel that are not interacting because when you turn it 90 degrees,
they indeed are not interacting because there are thug and all.
Okay.
An amine,
as we said,
should be basic and a carbon eel should be acidic because of the law.
Lumo the Pi Star CEO,
but if they mix with one another,
then the homo is lower and the Lumo is higher,
so they're not reactive at a more,
they're not as unusual in their highness and their lowness.
Right.
So it turns out that the mid is relatively unreactive.
Now,
do you know relative to what you'd expect for an amine and a carbonyl now,
do you know where you encounter amids all the time?
You can touch it amid with no problem.
How Sofi?
Pardon?
Pardon me?
You acids,
amino acids which make proteins.
Mito acids aren't amends,
but proteins which are made of amino acids and amine reacting with a car,
but those are a mids and you want them to be stable.
Why?
You don't want them to be our active like a carbonyl and an amine.
It's so your skin works.
Otherwise,
in lab,
if you,
what does a base,
if you feel sodium hydroxide,
you've done this,
what does it feel like?
It's slippery.
If a bed's weren't unusually stable right?
Then when you felt at your skin would go away.
Right.
So it's a good thing.
In fact,
uh,
and the last thing I was also important,
so you're opposing dipoles mostly,
right?
Carbon to oxygen is pl is plus towards carbon minus toward oxygen,
carbon,
nitrogen plus toward carbon minus toward nitrogen.
But mostly those two are opposed to one another and a little bit they add.
So you get a net displacement of positive negative charge in the molecule from
left to right,
positive to negative.
Okay.
That's what would happen if it were a carbon eel and a mean,
but it's not a carbon eel and a mean.
It's strongly dipole are not canceled and it's in this direction perpendicular
to the original direction because you take electrons that were on nitrogen and
the amine and you shift them into the carbonyl group.
So it's as if the,
the magnitude of that effect is as if you transferred one third of an electron
from nitrogen to oxygen.
If you did that,
you'd get as much displacement of charge on average.
Is there actually is right now.
It turns out that all these ladder properties are crucial for structural
biology.
We already saw that if you want skin to work,
it has to not be as reactive,
but these other things are important to the geometric things that nitrogen has
to be playing or not.
There's a barrier to rotation is very important and also the dye polarity,
the direction of the dipole is very important and will show that.
So here's,
here's an amid bond,
okay,
the nitrogen is blue and the oxygen is is red.
You see the double bond,
but you shift electrons from the nitrogen to the carbon group and that is the Pi
Star.
That's proper.
That's the,
that's the,
that's the Homo,
not the Pi Star.
It's the,
it's the homo,
the pie electron pair,
which is shifted from nitrogen and shared with the CW Bondo.
Now that sharing is,
we just said on the previous slide creates an electric dipole.
So the electrons are shifted in the direction shown.
And that's crucial because here is a picture of a helix,
an Alpha helix of a protein,
and I outline the backbone of it there.
Okay.
So several turns of an Alpha Helix,
which has a lot of amid bonds in it.
And if we look at it,
we see there's an a mid,
there's another amid,
there's another amid all,
more or less on the top of this helix.
What's interesting about those,
Andrew?
What's interesting about the set of them?
Uh,
how are they up there?
You think it's favorable or unfavorable?
The way they're aligned up plus minus,
plus minus,
plus minus in a row,
they're all lined up so as to be attractive to one another.
So that stabilizes this structure.
In fact,
another way of talking about it is to say as as shown here by these deltas that
the oxygen is partially minus and that the hydrogen attached to the nitrogen is
partially plus.
So getting this minus near that plus is favorable.
What do you call that?
Anybody know that is a hydrogen bond,
right?
So you'd have,
it's a stabilized by electrostatic interaction.
These hydrogen bonds,
not only there,
but there are other ones too,
like here,
a chain of them there and another chain down here at the bottom.
So this helix is stabilized by the fact that the dipole points,
the way it did,
if it pointed in the perpendicular direction,
you wouldn't get this stability.
Okay?
And it's also stabilized by the geometry that's favored the local play
narrative.
The fact that you don't twist around the CN double bond.
So here's the partial double bond.
So here's Carbonell,
here's the CN.
And that's partially,
although it's written as a single bond,
it's partially a double bond.
So you don't twist about it.
So this item,
this item,
this Adam,
are all in the same plane,
right?
And you'll see another such group here,
back behind where here is the,
is the bond in question.
So this item,
this item,
this Adam,
we're all in the same plane or here at the bottom you see it where you,
you're looking almost in the line in the plane,
right?
And what does that mean?
It means that the backbone is not as floppy because you take away some of the
possibilities of twisting it.
So it helps it take this shape.
So both the dipole and the fact and the geometrical freezing of some of the
single bonds means that,
that,
that this structure is a particularly stable and therefore a very,
uh,
prevalent in biological macromolecules.
So that makes a lot of difference that of mids,
our mids and not a mean carbon eels.
Okay.
Now how about carboxylic acids?
That's the next functional group.
So let's come compared with water,
they asked,
are they acidic compared to alcohols?
Because you might think that in the same way that an amid is an amine key tone,
you might think that a carboxylic acid is an alcohol ketone,
but it's not right.
They interact with one another in much the same way.
Now,
if you had just a regular old alcohol,
it can associate as an acid.
It's not very strong as an acid.
You don't burn your skin with it,
right?
But it,
uh,
it has a,
so it has a pka of 16 that's the,
the dissociation constant is 10 to the minus 16.
That's not very impressive.
But for a carboxylic acid,
the reason it's called an acid is because it's PKA is much lower.
It's more acidic.
The equilibrium constants,
10 to the minus five so it's acidic.
It's not an alcohol,
it's 10 to the 11th times stronger than an alcohol.
Right.
And why now?
Why?
Well,
just like an amid,
you have an unshared pair on the Oah oxygen,
which could be stabilized by the,
by the Pi Star,
orbital of the CW Bondo.
Now,
if that stabilizes the material on the left,
how should it affect the equilibrium constant?
Should it be it more or less acidic?
That is because of this interaction.
Because of this residence structure,
we could say because this pair of electrons is stabilized by the carbon eel,
there's a factor that stabilizing this,
which doesn't exist in the alcohol.
So you're stabilizing the material on the left of the equilibrium.
Would that tend to make it more acidic or tend to make it less acidic if it's
stable on the left,
right.
You so you have,
here's the stuff on the left.
Here's the stuff on the right.
It's uphill and energy,
no matter what you're talking about,
it's hard to dissociate as an acid,
right?
So I make this more stable,
which is what I just showed.
There's resonance here that stabilizes this Homo Lumo mixing within the
molecule.
Does that make it more or less easy to dissociate?
Harder or easier?
Harder.
Right.
It's further up hill,
so this seems backwards.
The stabilization that we saw in the analog of the stabilization we saw in an
amid that makes your skin not dissolve has the opposite direction.
It predicts that the,
that the dissociation would be more uphill where in fact it's less.
Why?
Because if we look at the product,
you also have homo Lumo interaction between an unshared pair on this oxygen and
the carbon eel and that will stabilize it on the right and make it easier to
dissociate,
which should be more important.
The amount of extra stabilization on the left.
Here's what it was for an alcohol or originally,
right.
We stabilize it on the left and we stabilize it on the right,
which is more stabilized.
The carb oxalate or the original alcohol,
the carboxylic acid.
What do you know from the fact that it's more acidic,
which must have gone down further.
This one must have gone down further.
Can you see why?
Why would this one be more stabilized by Homo Lubo mixing that?
Is this be more important than it is here
with that
Lucas symmetry?
No.
Charge separation.
Okay.
There's bad charge separation here.
Here you don't on the right you don't separate charge.
That may have been part of what Lucas was trying to say,
but there's another way you can say it.
Just in terms of Homo Lumo mixing,
you're the language you're using is the language of resonance,
right?
That you don't want a separate charge.
I want to see why in terms of molecular orbital energies are atomic orbital
energies that you get more stabilization here,
Alex.
Yeah,
right,
but that's true in both cases is an electron pair here that mixes with the
vacant orbital.
There's an electron here,
like tron pair here that mixes with the vacant orbital.
Why is it more effective here than it is here?
Player?
Just guessing,
but the residents with the two structures in the left,
the residence on the sit down the,
Ooh,
his,
but with the other one,
because the age is in there.
It's actually what can get even more stable.
I have to think about that a while,
but I want you to try him in terms of the what makes homo Lumo indirect mixings
good.
What makes them important?
Overlap.
That's the same in both cases it's the same.
Oxygen reactive mixing with the same don't want.
And what else?
If there's high,
if it's a high homo,
what do you,
how would you say,
well,
what's the,
how would the homo here,
the homo here is an unshared payer on oxygen.
The whole low here.
Does it unshared pair on US agenda?
Are they the same?
No,
because the on the on the left is taken up by the hydrogen.
Right.
Okay,
so the one on the left has another proton,
which this one doesn't.
That means that the electrons here are more stable,
lower in energy,
and this is a higher hormone which is associated.
Another way of saying the same thing with the fact that that's a negative
charge.
When you have a negative charge,
it's a bad place to put electrons.
They're high in energy.
Another way of setting and the way you said it,
which is probably a better way of saying it,
is that the proton is gone so it's not stable.
So you expect more humble Lumo mixing here because of better energy match.
Then on the left there for the observation that it's 10 to the 11th time,
stronger as an acid.
So it's a higher homo because of that negative charge or the absence of a
proton.
Okay,
so there's our carboxylic acid and the last functional group we wanted to talk
about today,
which is a really complicated one.
I mean it starts very simple but you'll see it gets pretty baroque pretty soon
here.
So its methyl lithium and the chance of your figuring all this stuff out ahead
of time is about zero,
right?
So don't be depressed if this looks like it's getting very complicated.
Remember there,
there are three approaches here.
One is the draw lines.
I'll I Lewis to understand how things come together.
Another one is to use a computer to generate molecular orbitals.
Two to break,
break the total electron distribution into orbitals and look at them one at a
time.
And having seen what the computer produces.
Some of those orbitals are interpretable as we've seen that they're anti bonding
in a certain region,
bonding in a certain region and so on,
but the chances of you're competing with the computer in drawing accurate
molecular orbitals to the extent that molecular orbitals are real,
the chance if you're competing with the computer is not very good.
So don't expect that you can exactly draw them.
But if you see the one that the computer is drawn,
at least in some cases you can make some guesses about it.
You can see how many nodes that has,
whether they're our nuclei in the middle of Lobes,
which would make that unstable orbital where it's bonding,
where it's anti-bonding,
those kinds of things you can analyze even though you can't produce them
yourself.
So don't think that you're going to be able to write.
But then there's another point of view,
which is to look at localized payers bonds and anti bonds and how they'll come
together.
Right.
And that you can do,
that's the intermediate between using just Louis and doing the full molecular
orbital kind of thing.
This is something you can do in your head and that's what we're going to show
these different points of view with this one.
So here's methyl lithium.
Now what will make methyl lithium reactive?
What's a high homo of methyl lithium?
Marty,
what makes Homo Deus?
What makes for a high homo?
What kind of things do you
think about?
Like with the lines,
just just with a pair of that.
I'm not trying to make like a slide before where you're doing all that and
stuff,
but just you have two atoms that come together.
Will they give a very high homeowner what determines how far they go up and down
the homeowner?
What's one thing in terms of overlap?
Okay,
so here are two atoms that are coming right together.
A single bond us and so good overlap.
Let's suppose it's the same as all overlap.
Okay,
what else?
what does it besides overlap determines how far is it?
Good energy.
The energy match right now what's special about methyl lithium?
Methyls not going to be funny.
That's our standard thing.
But lithium is funny.
Where is it?
On the periodic table?
Maybe that's the problem we're having
on the far left,
which means it doesn't have a very big nuclear charge.
So does that mean electrons are going to like me in there and not like being
there
because it's not much nuclear charge,
so it's going to be a bad energy match.
High Energy.
So there's going to be a high homo,
right?
The Homo here from the carbon doesn't go down very much because of the bad
energy manager.
Okay,
so this is an unusually high homo.
What will it look like?
Where will it be on the carbon or on the lithium?
The homeowner.
Is it good?
Is it going to be symmetrical or is it going to be more carbon?
Are going to be more lithium,
more on the carbons.
That's the lower one.
Okay.
So if we want to look at the homo,
this thing,
it's going to be mostly on carbon,
not so much on lithium and an unusually high homo because of the lithium and
there it is.
That's the homo.
Marty,
you're going to finish this here by saying what Oracle does it look like?
I'll
up
here it is.
And there's the orbital.
It's the two p orbital on carbon,
mostly right with just a little bit of lithium,
one s or two s pardon me on it,
but just a teeny bit of lithium and it's anti bonding between the lithium and
the carpet.
It's the or no,
no wait,
it must be a p orbital on lithium because it's the favorable one.
It's the bonding one,
right?
We see the red,
but there's a little,
we see the blue of the lithium,
but there's a little red on the other side that we don't see that making a net,
which I didn't do.
Okay,
so that's the whole Mo.
It's a sigma.
Now what will the Lumo B,
Hey,
what do you say?
What?
What do you think for a little while of methyl lithium?
Can't hear very well.
Yeah,
don't.
Lithium has a lot of vacant orbitals on the atom,
right?
It comes in with only one valence electron.
Only one of its four valence orbitals is occupied.
So it's got in fact three vacant orbitals.
So that's gotta be Lumo.
There's the Lumo mostly on the lithium.
Okay.
Now,
but the Lumo plus one is this orbital,
which I've drawn in a funny way at a very,
at a relatively high d electron density contour,
making the things
very small because if I've made a bigger,
it goes way off the top of the sheet and off the bottom of the sheet cause the,
this orbital isn't held very tightly by lithium.
It's sticks way out and it turns out to be out of the range that gets plotted by
Spartan.
So you get funny looking holes and the orbital.
So I chose this particular density,
but anyhow,
you see it's a PR battle,
right?
That's different sides top and bottom.
Now.
So you have a,
is this an unusually low Lumo?
Monique,
what do you say?
I'll let me say something.
I say lithium has a small nuclear
charge,
not a very good place for electrons to be.
Right.
Which means that,
that,
that it's that it's got to be very high orbital energy.
Can you see any contrary things and say it might be unusual.
Hello?
Yeah,
here for long I think it would be
because of the low nuclear charge compared to what?
What are we comparing with to say whether oracles or higher levels,
the carbon carbon or carbon,
hydrogen sigma and Sigma Star bonds.
Right.
So clearly enough the carbon and hydrogen start lower in energy than the lithium
does,
but one,
but they have big overlap.
So sigma star is quite high,
much higher than lithium because it's an atomic or bullet hasn't mixed with
anything.
This one.
Okay,
so it isn't so,
so methyl lithium has an unusual,
yeah.
Low vacant orbital and an unusually high occupied orbital.
And what do you expect?
You ever seen a case like this before where the same molecule was both Bh three.
It's very for the exactly the same reason,
right?
Except more so because lithium is more so than Boron being further to the left
of the periodic table.
So we can put two of these things above a up and down from one another like this
and have the whole role of one be stabilized by the Lumo of the other,
uh,
strike.
Do you again why it has a little bit about,
yeah,
because it's an atomic orbital.
It's not
killer,
but it's not a bonding.
Orbitals didn't mix with other things.
The things we're comparing with are not carbon and hydrogen,
which are in fact lower than lithium.
It's the sigma and Sigma Star bonds of carbon and hydrogen,
which,
and this,
the Lumo here is higher than that of lithium lithium's unusually low because
it's still an atomic orbital didn't mix with anything.
Okay.
So there's stabilization of the sigma by the Pi,
but at the same time we can go the other way on the homo on the top can be
stabilized.
The Lumo on the bottom.
Same as in Bh three giving B two h six.
Okay,
so these things dimerize.
They come together,
Homo of one,
stabilizing the Lumo or the other and vice versa.
They move together and you get a thing that looks like that very much like B two
h six right?
So you have two vacant Lithia,
more bundles,
stabilizing the unshared pair of carbon.
You can think of it that way.
And it also goes the other way.
The unshared pair on that carbon is stabilized by two vacant lithium's.
Okay.
So these are three center to electron bonds just as in B,
two h six.
Okay.
Now,
but remember lithium has two other vacant orbitals each Adam,
we've only used one here,
right?
So they can combine to give this,
this is actually the Lumo of that dimer,
right?
Those are in the plane of the four membered ring,
And there's another,
there are other vacant orbitals too,
like this pie one,
which is in and out from that four membered ring made up of p orbitals on the
lithium.
That's the Lumo plus one of that dimer.
Okay,
now I'm going to rotate this.
Now pay attention here because it's it.
Get the picture.
The next picture is a little confusing.
I'm going to rotate this thing so that we're looking just a little bit.
Uh,
we're looking mostly in the plane of the molecule,
but twisted a little bit so we can see it.
Still see the top of the molecule,
and we're going to twist it such that the red lobe in back is behind the red
lobe in front.
So what we're going to do is rotate around that axis and shift it tore a little
bit toward the center of the picture.
So it's that same orbital and there it is now,
but it's a little confusing in the middle because there's one red lobe in the
back and one in the front.
Okay?
Uh,
we could,
we could draw it down.
Okay,
so that's what it is.
But we're going to drop an access that goes right through the middle of that
square,
that a parallelogram.
Okay?
And now along that axis,
we're going to bring up another molecule,
but it's going to be rotated 90 degrees.
So those are the same,
the same two orbitals Lumo plus one.
In both cases,
the one bottom has rotated 90 degrees around the axis I drew.
Okay?
Now will those things interact favorably with one another?
And even if they,
their first,
they're orthogonal and second,
even if they mixed,
you wouldn't care.
Why?
Because there mate.
So what we want to do is look at the bottom,
not that Lumo plus one.
We want to look at the whole mo of that one,
that diamond,
which looks like this.
And now you see something neat that the blue in front overlaps the blue vacant
one and the red and back up right pop overlaps the behind red vacant one.
So the electrons in the home or on the bottom get stabilized by overlapping with
the Lumo plus one on the top.
And of course,
by the same token,
the homo of the one on top overlaps with the Lumo of the one on the bottom like
that.
So we already had two molecules come together to form dimers.
Now we're having two dimers come together to form a tetramer [inaudible]
uh,
because that's the one that does the overlap,
the actual Lumo does it overlap?
This one on the bottom?
Okay,
looking that,
does that mean essentially,
then you go because it's more stabilized.
Uh,
well,
but it mixes with this one.
So the Lube oil plus one and this one interact right?
Here's the homo and they made move plus one.
So the,
okay,
so the look,
so it contributes to this one,
right?
When this,
when the Hobo here of the dimer mixed with the Lumo plus one of the other diver,
you've got a mixture.
This one looks mostly like the Hobo,
this dimer,
but it's a little bit helped out by looking at like the Lumo of this one.
There's a new vacant or a little bit,
it's still hire.
You don't care about that one anymore.
Okay,
so now we can take two of these and bring them together.
That's a bonding.
The orbitals we just showed
and you get a cube,
right?
So here's the one on the bottom.
One,
two,
three,
four and here's the one on the top.
One,
two,
three,
four and they've been turned 90 degrees to line up these orbitals and they come
together and the electrons to get more stable.
Now that used on every lithium,
another one of its vacant orbitals
right?
But what Angela,
there's another one.
Okay,
so the homeowner
now turns out to be this,
and you can understand that the biggest part of it,
by seeing that it's a four center to electron bond,
mostly it's a p orbital or a hybrid orbital of the carbon.
And unshared pair of carbon,
but it stabilized by three vacant orbitals of lithium.
So three vacant lithium atomic orbitals,
stabilized on shared pair of carbon.
But as Angela points out here,
there's another one that's a still a vacant orbital on lithium that's on the top
lithium.
There are other ones on the other three lithium's.
So we need more electrons or it's capable of stabilizing more electrons.
Where do you get them?
Well,
you might think you bring another Cuba,
but in
fact there's something easier to do because this is done in solution.
And the solution,
the solvent is dyed methyl ether as shown here or some other ether,
which has an unshared pair of electrons and it comes along and get stabilized by
that.
But at the same time,
the other three oxygens,
the other orange balls,
uh,
the,
the other three lithium's I should say,
stabilize oxygen's of other ethers.
So you have for ether molecules associated with the tetramer of methyl lithium.
And this is about as complex as we're ever going to get,
right?
So I think you would have had a hard time at the outset predicting this.
But having seen it,
I think you can understand it.
That's what we're aiming for at this stage
because as we go on and get lore that this reacts with this and gives this the,
what I want you to be able to do is to look at it and say,
Aha,
that's what happened.
That's why that reacted that way.
Not necessarily in some cases you'll be able to predict,
but in other cases you'll be able to understand and correlate it with what you
know.
So if you put more ether in,
if it's,
you have a lot of excess ether,
then it rips these things apart so it can fly a party.
You get a bunch of ethers on every lithium.
Right.
And in fact,
this is,
this is a further,
uh,
development of organic chemistry beyond what we usually do in a elementary
chorus,
which is to understand the non bonded interactions.
Because often you wouldn't consider that oxygen lithium to be a real bond is
just sort of a weak salvation thing.
Although truly it is a bond.
Okay.
So these so called non bonded interactions and the effects of solvent are a
vital part of Lore.
What solve it.
You choose for a given reaction.
Uh,
for example,
if you want to facilitate ionization,
you use certain solvents and not other solvents.
And we'll talk about that a little bit,
but I just want you to show what to show you what there is out there beyond the
bonding that we've already talked about.
But we've,
we've really taken theory pretty far here in the first half of the first
semester of the course.
Now,
uh,
I said we would vote and I forgot to bring a piece of paper.
I have this piece of paper,
but I'm not gonna use it for that cause this is the thank you note.
So if you want to,
if you haven't signed what's fastened around,
cause there are few people who haven't signed it.
Well let's pass it down,
back and forth,
down the aisles.
I think most people have signed it,
but some have it,
you don't have to.
And uh,
you also don't have to contribute.
But if you want to be,
uh,
have a sense of satisfaction of having contributed to the class gift,
you can leave a small coin on the table over there.
Okay.
But the other business we have to transact is,
I'm going to give a review session before the exam,
but it's not obvious when we should give it.
So I decided that the easiest thing to is to see how many people cannot,
how many people,
not first.
We want people,
not only that can,
but would come,
right?
If you could come,
but wouldn't,
you're irrelevant.
So the question is how many people cannot err,
uh,
would come other times,
but cannot come at the time shown.
And the one that has the fewest will win.
That makes sense.
Okay.
So how many people cannot come?
Uh,
uh,
Thursday evening,
eight o'clock.
That's too many.
However,
eight 30
the here we have about that.
My judges,
about 15.
Uh,
how many,
uh,
how many cannot come in Friday afternoons.
Lab.
Okay.
Uh,
how many people could not come Saturday?
Early
Salon.
How many a Saturday at 10.
Can I,
how many Saturday at two?
How many Sunday?
Uh,
how many Sunday?
One to three.
Well,
bear in mind that there's also the ta session Sunday evening.
I think it's better if I do it.
Uh,
you know,
two days before the exam rather than the day before.
But on the other hand,
none of these earlier times can get there.
They're always at least 15 people.
Let,
let me,
let me see about,
about option two.
That was the one Thursday at eight 30.
How about if it were nine?
How many,
how many could not come up?
Was at nine Thursday evening,
tomorrow evening.
That actually is.
And what,
let's see,
Sunday again,
Sunday,
early sometime,
early afternoon.
Those are,
they're actually more who can't come on Sunday then Thursday.
So I'm sorry,
but it'll be a Thursday.
It could be eight 30 or nine in.
Does it make a difference?
Is there somebody who'd come?
If we started at nine,
pardon me,
Saturday what?
Saturday was pretty bad.
But let me see.
Saturday nine.
Yeah,
that's worse.
Saturday,
10 Saturday to Saturday 8:00 PM
so it'll be,
it'll be tomorrow.
It'll be tomorrow night.
It'll be tomorrow night at eight 30 and I'll send you an email once I got a
room.
Okay,
let's continue.
so to summarize,
the first half of the semester we've seen amazing modern tools that show us
molecules,
the real thing at the level of angst drums and at the timescale of picoseconds
10 to the minus 12 seconds.
Uh,
we've seen scanning probe microscopy that can feel Adams and,
and x Ray de fraction that can see them and can see bonds with difference
density.
We've seen spectroscopy,
IRR and Esr and next semester we'll talk about nuclear magnetic resonance.
So there are amazing tools,
not only experimental tools,
but theoretical tools.
This stuff about quantum mechanics so that then people believe quantum mechanics
enough that they talk about doing calculations on a computer as experiments,
right?
Rather than just things you do in the lab.
So that's amazing.
Right?
And it all has developed fairly recently,
say since the Thai.
Uh,
most of the important things we've talked about have developed since I was in
graduate school.
But what's amazing is that organic chemists were not at all surprised when they
were finally able to see these things because they already knew what they looked
like.
So it wasn't surprising.
It was,
it was satisfying.
And there were a few little queer things that are understood better now than
they were before,
certainly.
Right.
And things like being able to generalize about what makes a functional group
that's completely new,
right?
But fundamentally what molecules look like and how atoms behave and that this
reacts with this.
That was already known.
So how could they possibly know it when they didn't have these tools?
And that's going to be our chore for the Next Quarter or the semester is to
figure out how they knew.
How did organic chemistry really developed.
And a reason for this is that if you know how it developed,
then you understand the language much better because the language we use isn't
the language of quantum mechanics.
Usually it's the language that developed during this a long gestation period.
And it started as we said before in the 17th century.
And we've gone on this and we've talked now about science,
the scientific method and forced laws and how we finally found out what the
force law was for Adams.
Right?
And in the 20th century,
this whole theoretical experimental stuff came together and we saw that bonds
were shared electrons and we could see them and the quantum mechanics could help
us to understand them.
But we've left out this middle period starting with the end of the 18th century
with Lavoie Zaa discovering oxidation and ending with the discovery of quantum
mechanics.
Cause this is the period during which most of organic chemistry developed.
And we have to see how it happened.
Okay.
So this,
if you've been here 107 years ago and been graduating,
you would have been in this picture with your,
uh,
with your,
fancy boots and so on.
Right?
This is the computer science building.
You walk up now,
it used to be the chemistry lab on the right.
You know where it is?
Watson Watson lab down there.
Okay.
So let's look at some,
see what they understood at the time.
They chalked things on the bricks to show show off their knowledge.
So here's ch four methane.
Obviously they knew that and here's the reaction of sulfuric acid with zinc,
which gives hydrogen.
They knew that.
And here,
what do you think?
That crazy thing is in the middle
that's a benzene ring and remember how it looks like,
but they confirmed at about the same time the clairvoyant people saw that that
valence is all went to the center.
Okay.
And down here you'll see another thing.
Those are probably aromatic rings with the double bonds not shown,
but an interesting thing that showed is that the Greek letters alpha and Beta
there,
those are symbols that are still used
to denote different positions that you can put substituents in the ring.
Okay.
This is inside the chemistry lab,
which was in asset where sss is now.
And uh,
you'll see things like,
like this,
right,
which came from that lab.
I'm sure there was a big box of them floating around here.
And I rescued one on one time to go.
The others got thrown out there.
And,
and what's,
what's that second Arrow?
There's another important tool.
Bunsen burner
Bunsen lit,
invented the burner about 1860 or something like that.
Or Seventies.
Okay.
Here there's one that looks just like this,
right?
Actually this isn't that old because it says on it,
uh,
West Germany.
So it's interesting.
Okay,
what do we see here?
The white thing,
mortar and Pestle,
they can grind things up right?
And there.
What's that?
It's a beer at dry upside notice.
That's the only quantitative tool.
So were there any other quantitative tools in this picture that they were
showing off?
Well,
there's some,
uh Huh.
Anything else that will give you a number?
Oh,
but that's just a crude balance,
right?
There were,
they had analytical balances but they weren't portable.
They couldn't let them out the prospect street from the picture.
Okay.
But that was
okay.
This guy here
look like that.
See Mail and climb class of 1901 s and you know his name because Glaxo Smith
Kline and he gave the money for the Cline biology tower in the Klein Chemistry.
Lie over the client.
Geology via to client.
But you can also measure Christmas
angles on crystals.
Right?
But that's about it.
Somehow with these tools,
they figured out where Adam's were in molecules.
Isn't that crazy?
So if you look at the front of the building,
you'll see down here he's wrapped and stuff now cause they're painting him,
Benjamin Solomon,
Yale's first scientists or first chemist anyhow,
and he's holding something.
He didn't see what he's holding
big flopping crystal.
That's where science was.
That that's what he's mostly known for his mineralogical things.
Okay.
But here on these plaques is something else.
This is the names of the people who actually developed all this stuff during
that 19th century.
So it starts in the 17th century actually with boil and the gas laws.
But that was way before notice.
He's a hundred.
He was born 120 years before the time we're talking about [inaudible].
So things happen,
but not a lot from our purposes during that period really got underway with the
second person.
These are,
these are in chronological order.
The second one is Lavoie [inaudible] and that's where we're going to start.
And then dailies doctorates alias fairly.
They were going to talk about these
people.
Okay.
And here is you and your cousins who did all this stuff because we have a family
tree here.
So there's you
and me.
And I studied quantum mechanics as a graduate student with Evie Wilson.
Right?
Who was a postdoc with Linus Pauling at cal tech who did ex-ray in proteins.
He's the first guy that saw the healer,
the proteins.
Okay.
And another postdoc.
Appalling was jack done it.
So we've talked about a lot.
So donuts who we've talked about a lot is your great uncle academically.
But if we go back around,
Oh,
and here are things.
Notice how many of these things,
the 20th century things we've talked about,
the shared that notice that that bold face is things that are experimental
and,
and uh,
normal faces is theoretical things.
Shared pair bonds me,
som or ISM,
which is resonance electron pair shifts,
the curved arrows,
quantum theory reaction mechanisms.
We already talked about a mo ammonia being oxidized by chlorine example,
IRS spectrus we talked about,
we haven't talked about,
well,
we've talked a little about polymers.
Not much.
We haven't done mass spectroscopy.
Well,
we did actually the problem set and the first thing,
right?
A confirmational analysis we'll do at the end of the semester x-ray.
We've talked about Nmr next semester.
Molecular orbital methods.
We've talked about a lot.
This is what we've been talking about that we'll do at the end of the semester.
A non covalent structure structures.
We just talked about a little bit,
scanning probe microscopes,
quite recent,
so on.
So we've actually talked about a lot of this stuff already,
the more recent stuff,
but what we want to talk about now is the earlier stuff,
how people discovered things in the 19th century.
So these are the guys that did it.
And in particular we're starting with Lavoie Ca.
But Lavoie was not the first altogether.
Uh,
but I'm going to have to wait until next time to tell you who was first.